[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and tonight we're going to have
much less fun compared to last week
we're not doing anything crazy
we're back to talking about chess and
chess strategy and hopefully how you
guys can improve at it of course last
week we had a fun class about some of
the longest chess puzzles out there uh
but it's back to the normal stuff this
week uh so to start with i've been
playing a lot of just 10 minute games
online on lee chess
and most of them are about the the
quality you would expect for a 10 minute
game but i did play one that i felt was
worth going over in a class and it
actually made me think of of the topic
for for tonight's class so we're going
to start with my my 10 minute game uh
which inspired the topic of exploiting
small weaknesses in your opponent's
position and understanding you know what
what is a weakness and a pawn structure
and how can you kind of try to exploit
that so we're going to see some obvious
weaknesses in some of these games and
some less obvious weaknesses and we're
going to see how you can try to sort of
exploit them
so to start with i was playing white in
this position my opponent was someone on
leeches named maple danish uh that 2400
rating that's just leech has rapid
rating don't get too excited he's he's
not that good he's he's pretty good but
not that good so to start with the game
went in d4 d5
c4 e6 knight c3 bishop e7
uh i played the exchange
and because of my opponent's move order
uh we're not going to go into the main
line here which would be bishop g5 with
the knight on f6
because my opponent i think is trying to
prevent this move for for whatever
reason but
white's doing totally fine here we can
just develop the bishop out to the other
square of course
i'm trying to develop the bishop on this
move because i want to play e3 to give
myself this nice structure i don't want
to lock the bishop in so bishop f4
my opponent plays c6
i play e3 all according to plan
and my opponent plays this move bishop
d6 so it might look really really weird
to go bishop e7 bishop d6 in fact lee
chess is showing um
showing a question mark exclamation
point i'm going to turn those off i hate
those um but this is actually an opening
line that's been played before if i
click over the database topolov has
played this sorry christian has played
this it's been played a few times uh the
idea is
with black we're just going to trade off
some of the pieces and try and get to an
equal equalish position
now in this game i wasn't feeling too
combative so i just captured on d6 that
brings my opponent's queen out but it
allows me to develop
and then my opponent plays this move
knight to e7
uh so this move might look a little
strange to you right normally the knight
comes out to f6 so let's try and
understand what's going on
why might black have played knight to e7
yeah brian
uh
bishop
yeah it's sort of keeping in line with
black's plans so far played bishop e7 to
d6 to trade off the dark squared bishops
uh now in order to not be worse black
really would like to get off the light
squared bishops as well because the
light squared bishop is my quote-unquote
good bishop it's probably my best minor
piece in the position because it sits
comfortably behind my pawn structure
it's relatively unassailable compared to
bishop on f4
and it controls these long open
diagonals puts a lot of pressure on both
sides of the board very versatile piece
uh meanwhile this bishop on c8 uh is the
quote-unquote bad bishop because it's on
the same color pawns it's on the same
color as black's pawn chain that means
the pawns interfere with the bishop and
you know one day this bishop could be a
good piece a nice active piece but it
would also be very happy to step to f5
making use of the knight on e7 uh in
order to trade itself off
and for those reasons um you might be
able to guess white's
two main moves in this position either
of them uh because they're played with
the idea of preventing black's plan
yeah those are actually exactly it queen
c2 is a lot more natural queen f3 has
also been played in the game i actually
just developed my knight so this should
more or less give black uh a quality
here you know black gets everything he
ever wanted gets to play bishop to f5
uh but you know i i wasn't too worried
about it it's a 10 minute game online i
just wanted to play chess so bishop f5
but for those of you at home queen c2
and queen f3 are just objectively better
moves you know why not prevents bishop
f5 and in fact
after queen c2 black often times will
play g6 really trying to force this idea
through
but in the game just knight g to e2 we
get bishop f5 and i go ahead and castle
my opponent takes the bishops off
and then really committing to this plan
plays queen to g6
and this is sort of a step too far in my
opinion so
black has really already succeeded in
getting everything he wants here he got
both bishops off the board i no longer
have the superior minor piece
and if black just for example castles or
develops knight d7 or something uh
there's really no reason why white
should be better here you know it's just
that it's a carl's badge structure both
sides get developed and it's a chess
game but instead after queen to g6
i think white is able to apply a little
bit of pressure so i'm curious if you
guys
can come up with the plan that i came up
with
to sort of punish black for for not
developing quickly enough
it's not the most usual way you would
punish a lack of development but it's
pretty effective
okay the chat has the more conventional
idea for trying to punish a lack of
development
uh they are talking about the move e4
which i'm actually not such a big fan of
here
yeah okay so knight to f4 is is pretty
interesting actually um it allows queen
takes queen but then that does a lot to
reroute your knight to a better square
where it's going to be eyeing the c5 and
e5 squares and yeah i like this idea a
lot more than e4 actually but i think
that i came up with the best move in the
game which is is not knight f4
um knight four probably maintains an
advantage but uh
i had a very very concrete idea
um i saw that if i play
with the most tempo the fastest then i
can get a really really desirable
plan to work right away
and now i'm at the point where i've
given so many hints that they you know
you sort of get lost thinking about the
hints and not the position so
i'll shut up give you a minute to think
about it and then i'll tell you what i
did
probably a very good move
all right any last second ideas
okay well we'll show it so i actually
traded the queens which is sort of the
antithesis of what you're supposed to do
uh to punish a lack of development
but the reason is is very concrete the
reason why i like this overnight f4 is
because knight f4 in a sense it's
gaining time because you get to move
your knight to d3 essentially for free
from e2
but in a sense it's losing time because
now black does get this extra turn to
develop uh
on the other hand if we just take on g6
ourselves
it's true that's uh this knight could
take back on g6 but this knight actually
really doesn't want to be here
because our pawn structure works very
well against it it's not really
advancing anywhere
or black can take back with the pawn
which of course as any beginner will
tell you uh doubled pawns are bad and
we'll look at that in a little bit
but more importantly than that that
gives us an extra tempo in the position
now we can do whatever we want um
and maybe we have a more useful move
here the knight e2 d3 which is
essentially what knight f4 would be
doing
so now that i've given you takes on g6
why was this tempo so important
and you might be surprised by the
evaluation here
once again the idea
is we're playing against black's
undeveloped pieces
allows us to get a pretty big advantage
all right the chat is on the money here
um
and let me because the chat already has
it let me ask you in a different way
what's the normal plan in this pawn
structure
we've got the carl's bed everybody loves
the carlsbad
you just do the minority attack you just
play b4
and it's especially powerful here
because black really is is just going to
have to allow this right away
um
for example if you try like a6
and castles or knight d7
um you're sort of a turn too slow right
you're sort of a turn too slow to do
anything to stop me you can't really
play c5 the d5 pawn falls because your
rooks can't get to the center quickly
enough
um and opening the a file which is sort
of supposed to be you know quote-unquote
uh the way black can can be okay here
sometimes well white's already on the a
file and you've still got some work to
do before you can contest me um
effectively
um
and so b4 just turns out to be really
really good here and if i cheat for a
moment and turn on the engine
black should play a6 but i'm already
plus 0.5 which is
uh definitely not nothing my opponent
plays knight d7 instead which gives him
a chance to transpose if i play a4 but
there's really no need to play a4 here i
just go b5 right away my opponent plays
knight b6 kind of a weird move but he's
heading for the c4 square and i just
take on b take on c6 take on c6 so
now uh white is is definitely gonna have
an edge here
number one we have this horribly weak c6
pawn and it doesn't really show many
signs of getting to the the c5 square uh
in number two
we are still ahead a little bit on time
we still have a move or two before black
gets fully castled and organized to sort
of advance our plans so
this is the structure that we're going
to have essentially for the rest of the
game and so i want to talk now about the
weaknesses in the structure i'm sure you
guys can tell me you know the biggest
weakness here for black
um go ahead shout it out
yeah the c6 and also c5 of course the
the square in front of the the backward
pawn is always weak as well
but what else is weak in this position
not necessarily just pawns but squares
as well
because i said we were going to return
to this idea of the double pawns being
weak right ask any beginner should never
have double pawns but this is a really
common structure you see it a lot at you
know high levels of play people really
aren't afraid of taking on g6 with an h
pawn
doesn't seem to make too many weaknesses
and
in fact i would go as far as to say most
people like don't even understand why
it it could be worse to have this pawn
on g6 than a square like h6 or h5
so
over on this side of the board taking on
g6 with the h pawn actually does create
a weakness or two that black is going to
have to look out for
and yeah the chat has it again the chat
has it again any ideas first
squares yeah weak squares or or pawns or
um
i'm thinking
if they want to play
i mean if they want to contest it it
would
create more weakness than something yeah
so
uh that that's exactly right e5 is one
of the squares that h takes g uh sort of
ironically weakens sort of indirectly um
the the more uh direct square that
weakens is of course g5 um because
h7 h6 is no longer available so how does
h7 takes g6 weaken the e5 square
well black would want to contest this
square by playing something like f6 but
f6 would now always give up you know the
g6 square as well and now that the g6
pawn would be weak
so uh e5 g5 c5 all sort of weaknesses in
in black's camp
and you know you can say that c6 is like
a major weakness but you know the e5 and
c5 or the e5 and g5 squares they seem
sort of less you know like game changing
like sure okay the g5 square is weak but
but how is that going to change the game
um but i just want you to be you know
cogs that cognizant of those scores sort
of existing because they they are going
to become really really important in a
little bit here so
i start with rook f2c1
um it just makes sense to put the rooks
opposite the weak pawn make sure that
pawn doesn't get to c5
my opponent plays king to d7 instead of
castles now
i play this move a4 which is actually a
pretty bad move um because it makes
weaknesses in in my own camp basically
uh so af4 first of all makes this pawn
weaker than if it were sitting on a2 and
it also weakens uh most importantly the
the b4 square a little bit so not my
best move my idea was that my opponent
would likely play a5 to stop my pawn
from gaining too much space then maybe i
could make use of those weaknesses
myself but not not my favorite move that
i've ever played i think better would
just be to continue uh yeah what's your
idea
brian i was just wondering how they're
going to use v4
well stay tuned stay tuned
um
now i play knight f4 which is the move i
i probably should have just started with
and your idea from earlier is still
totally correct we want this knight on
d3 we want to be able to target these
weak squares in the enemy camp
my opponent plays knight to c4
i bring the knight to d3 and then here
we go rook fb8 and this is what my
opponent has in mind and obviously d3 is
not the square i want my knight to to
end the game on by any means so if it
has to babysit the b4 square i'm i'm not
entirely happy
so now let's see if you guys can come up
with an interesting idea here to really
improve white's position
uh
it's a few moves long but
it is uh
something you might not expect
so let's see what you guys got
the chat is also pointing out are we
going with the principle of two
weaknesses and maybe that will uh be a
factor in this game as well we've got
big weakness on the queen side
and then we need to see if we can turn
something over here
into a weakness
we can stretch the black forces thin
and
and make it a fight
all right the chat is uh
going with active ideas as always
and we'll talk about those chats ideas
we'll talk about them
someone in the chat wants to play the
move knight to e2 which is definitely
not the first move that comes to mind
but i think what he's saying is
he wants to bring in this knight for
backup as well that's certainly
interesting
and of course the chat is is
still talking about this move e4 trying
to uh
advance in the center fight for the c4
square somehow
also a very important idea here
but i chose none of those
does it moves
maneuvering your c3 knife i feel like it
could be somewhere else
yeah so that's a good question to start
asking yourself you know this knight it
seems sort of destined for the c5 square
maybe one day it'll jump to e5 but right
now i don't really want to allow knight
takes e5
so
the question is you know what what is
this knight doing on c3 and no
not quite as uh
not quite as as high level as knight b1
ben feingold joke um but it is it is a
pretty interesting maneuvering idea with
this knight that i wanted to enact here
and yeah we'll talk about e4 be patient
be patient but i want to show this idea
first because e4 is a little bit less uh
less clear what's going on
so it doesn't start with knight e2
no so knight e2 is maybe a fine move but
if you give black a lot of time here
like rook b okay well rook b3 would be a
pretty big mistake but if you give black
a lot of time here maybe he's gonna do
some work to improve his structure over
here on on the king's side maybe stuff
like g5 f6 and then all of a sudden
once those pawns sort of get organized
they're a lot harder to attack you know
the the light squares
this knight sort of slots nicely into
and uh
it would get tough so g5 and f6 is sort
of
sort of the threat here
well i was i was thinking maybe like h4
and then the i feel like the maneuver
two of the knight
on c3 to f4 is that makes a bit more
sense
g5
yeah i i really like this move h4 uh and
it does show up later in the game
but
uh i wanted you guys to put on your
tactic hats for a second so i started
with knight c5
and then my big idea here was that king
d6 seemed like the most natural move and
then i had this idea of playing knight
to e4 check
and the point is we can get to this g5
square very very quickly uh like this
and so this was my big idea it turns out
tactically that's uh that black is
actually doing okay after d takes e but
that's not that's not very clear at all
um to my mind by the way f5
the the only move here to defend the
pawn
in my mind i was seeing this position in
this rapid game and i thought that i
could could get some stuff rolling with
with something like f3
but it turns out
uh black is actually doing okay after
some surprising moves here like like f4
and things get really crazy here but but
black is doing okay
um so my idea turns out not to be the
best idea in position um e4 i think is
still a little bit early but no e4 is
actually the the single best idea
um
and you guys i think we're pretty on
point with everything that you that you
were saying you want to take on d5 you
want to take on c4
um
i was thinking that i would play e4 in
this position uh even as well
here apparently it's less good because
of knight d2 so the chat just showing me
up e4 in this position
was the perfect timing um instead i do
this knight e4 idea
um but you know i want to claim one up
on the chat here if not for d takes e4
this is the best line for for white and
i didn't think d takes e4
was really going to be working for black
it just turns out that it did and that's
the problem with 10-minute chess you
don't have time to calculate anything
but yeah e4 very strong idea by the chat
as well you know the same sort of stuff
you want to
shake up this knight you want to get at
the weaknesses and you want this knight
to have access into the game whether
it's through e4 or through d5
it's all about improving your worst
piece
so in the game we go for this my
opponent does not call my bluff plays
king to c7 and now we just plant this
knight on the g5 square and it's really
really tough here for for black to do
anything
um you've got this horribly weak pawn on
f7 which again you might not have
expected to be the biggest weakness for
for black to deal with here
but you certainly don't want to play f6
you certainly don't want to play f5
because then you're you're faced with
knight knight to e6 and that is not the
change in structure that's going to to
save your your your pawns so black's
already in a very very difficult uh spot
here
the computer gives it something like
plus one uh because
now you just have too many weaknesses
and this is the the idea that made me
want to show off this game because
you really don't expect when you play h
takes g that there's going to be a
knight on g5 that you just can't kick
away and that's what we have here so
wanted to highlight that this pawn
structure does actually come with with
deficits they might not be immediately
obvious uh and they might not show up in
the games very often but they certainly
can show up and it's something to be
aware of so this is the uh the small
weakness in the position that i was
hoping you guys could could exploit um
in the game black played knight back to
d6
uh it's the only reasonable way really
to defend this this pawn
and now i double up the rooks on the c
file
uh perfectly natural and then we're
going to bring in your idea from earlier
h4 is very certainly a very strong move
in this position we just further want to
lock down this square keep these double
pawns right where they're at because
that's where they're going to be the
weakness
the weakest not allow the opponent to
play something like f6 g5 at any moment
in this game
by the way
not a bad idea to have this pawn on h4
because it gets the pawn a little bit
closer to cleaning which might
turn out to be relevant
my opponent plays king to b6 uh he's
doing some some weird maneuvering over
here but it's with the idea of
eventually freeing up this knight to
come back to c4 i think that's that's
what's going on um i continue with the
move g4 now we sort of have all of our
pieces really well placed so i set about
going uh going to gain more space here
on the king's side maybe improve my king
and i was just going to take my time
wait for the right moment to
to activate
my opponent plays knight to g8 which is
a little bit weird
but you know maybe maybe the knight is
coming this way
and then i i continue playing slow it
turns out the idea i played in the game
could have been played a move earlier
but i go king g2 instead
now knight to c4
and now wait to move again let's see if
you can find the idea that uh
that finally is going to to open things
up for us
finally it is time to
get our pieces
fully active we did a great job of
locking down
the weaknesses
we have full control over the square in
front of the c6 pawn this pawn on f7
also not gonna not gonna be going
anywhere or night very well placed
but how can we get our rooks active
okay e4 once again um but now e4 is
actually going to be a little bit more
dangerous than it was before i think
because
don't forget this rook has has landed on
the b4 square and
okay
it's very easy to blunder something here
so forgive me if i if i am but let's say
knight to
i don't know either d6 or a3 let's say
d6
you could take obviously but let's say
e5
um
and yeah i'll give you knight to b7 as
well
okay now i'm playing awfully all right i
gotta cheat i can't do it i can't play
off the cuff like this
uh apparently knight of six is the best
here and okay white is still doing very
well white is still doing very well
um so e4 always a good move you guys are
you guys are right
um e4 is good but it's not what i played
in the game not what i played in the
game
and i think that what i did in the game
maybe is
a little bit clearer it's again going to
be another tactical idea
oh god now there's a pole in the chat
and i can't see any more oh okay it
moved
um subakara says if knight d 693 in that
line okay knight d6 was bad but against
knight d3 i'm hoping there's still at
least rook c4 i'm hoping i didn't miss
that much
okay knight g to e4 is also a very good
move the move that i tried is knight to
d3 but yeah once again we can actually
use this idea of uh
of the e4 square once again to activate
along the c file and for some some real
weaknesses f5 not going to be saving the
day anymore uh partially because we have
this pawn on g4 that can capture but
also because our king is going to get
very very active
but knight d3 is what i played instead
and let's see what the point is so the
point is if you save the rook
uh i come in with rook to be one check
this loses to checkmate not great
king to c7
allows knight takes on f7 and then all
of a sudden
the knights uh are sort of swarming in
and we have access on the b file and
have axis on the c file after knight to
e5 and these pawns are now doubled and
isolated and white is just uh just
totally totally killing it here
um in the game my opponent decided it
was best just to give up the exchange
with f6 uh he could have put on a lot
better resistance with something like
knight to f6 king to g3 and then taking
on a4 but instead just f6
i get to take on b4
takes back i bring the knight in
rook takes on a4
i play rook to b1
uh blundering a fork with knight a3 but
there's actually a number of ways to end
the game here rook to a2 was the
simplest i missed it and played knight
to c5 in the rapid game uh now if the
brook moves i take the check so we
simplified into this end game
uh which is
not entirely worth worth talking about i
think notably the king can't ever really
advance here i just have rick b3
and so black is is pretty much dead uh
we play some moves
i eventually come take this pawn
and take this other pawn
and take this other pawn and black
resigns so once the rook came off the
board like that uh the game was was
pretty much over but uh your guys ideas
were all very good as well um
which was after knight c4 e4 i think
does do a very good job of maintaining
the advantage you have to be careful of
these moves though
um and knight g to e4 i think is just
the objectively best move um
you're you know you're coming back with
the knight you're getting rid of the
knight on c4
and you have successfully clamped down
all of these pawns on the king's side
so what what are the important parts of
this game uh there's a few things uh
number one is just understanding that
even though material is is totally equal
here
uh
and you know maybe black thinks he has
the c6 weakness managed with this knight
coming to c4
white is going to have a pretty big
advantage an even bigger practical
advantage in positions like these
number two um take note when when
there's a deficit in the pawn structure
when there's a defect somewhere because
it does make these squares like g5 and
e5 just a little bit softer and it's
important not to allow um
you know not not to play things like 92
here i think because 92 again
something like g5 and
hopefully i'm not blundering anything
yet i don't think i am
uh yeah something like g5 and f6 and
then the squares become a lot harder to
access and maybe black can put up a lot
more resistance
um
okay so questions on on this game i know
it was a 10 minute rapid game and we
just spent half an hour analyzing it but
i do think the positions were pretty
interesting so any questions here
nothing for me all right
fair enough let's move on then to some
better chess players uh namely two
ground protrusion uh once again the
world champion not the cheater i always
have to specify
um against enrique uh mekking who is not
a player i know very much about but i
know he's been on the bad end of a few
very famous games this this being one of
them
uh so let's go over this game and see
how petrosian is is able to make use of
some weaknesses so
uh d4 knight f6 knight of three e6
we end up in this uh
normal looking tory uh knight b to d2
takes on d4
which is i guess the the start of the
deviation from modern day theory
not that the theory in the tory is is
all that's uh
all that important
and we get h6 uh h6 pushing this bishop
back and so already you know h6 uh
usually a desirable move for black in
many instances but does come with some
weaknesses namely the the light squares
always going to be a little bit weak
we get bishop back to f4 knight h5 push
back to e3 knight f6 and then bam knight
e5 and all of a sudden we get a big
change in structure takes on e5 takes on
e5 and knight d7
and bishop to d4
so i think this is the first moment well
actually let's go a couple moves further
because we play another another couple
forcing moves let's pause here so knight
c5 we move the bishop black plays a5
so let's try and assess what's going on
in this position so
first of all what sort of deficits in
the black structure can you start to
pick out already what is petrosian
trying to target
in this structure
b5 and b6 okay
we'll just we'll we'll get the full list
i'm not i'm not counting those squares
out just yet
james duggan says maybe the g6 square
just had to check my move count there
uh ricardo says g7 even just go after
the pawn somehow
so i'm sort of asking you this question
to move early
uh right now yes there are some
weaknesses right the pawn has been
pushed to h6 this pawn has been pushed
to e6 that sort of softens up these two
squares but i mean what what's the big
deal right it's not like your f7 and g7
pawns are going anywhere
um and on the queen side uh yes a5 might
make some weaknesses here but this is
sort of a red herring because uh in
structures like this the queen side is
normally where black is trying to play
so it looks like these squares are weak
but i mean black is is trying to play
like b5 b4 later this game and and so
that's where black is trying to open
things up so yeah it's relevant that
these squares could be weak maybe one
day a4 is a good idea
to lock things down over here
uh but it's not going to be the most the
most relevant yet
but the big trick here
is that petrosian has a really nice idea
that's going to clarify the weaknesses
a lot more in just a move or two
puts black in a really difficult spot
so right now
some minor weaknesses but nothing to
write home about but petrosian is aiming
to provoke bigger weaknesses
yeah f4 f5 so that's going to be a
really common plan in in these positions
but um
that's more just attacking the structure
that you currently have petrosian finds
a nice idea that forces black to weaken
the structure even further before before
going after it but f45 is is a perfectly
normal plan and yeah you would want to
castle and and then continue uh f4 f5
so i'm not going to say you're wrong
yeah the chat says h4
and then the chat also says in those
days they didn't play h4 not necessarily
true but in this case a pawn is a pawn
is a pawn and black is gonna take it
yeah queen g4 is actually really nice
here for for white uh and the point is
there's no comfortable way to defend
this and in fact there's so much not a
comfortable way to defend this that
black is
almost obliged to just move this pawn
forward
and that's what happens in the game just
g6
uh and this is obviously
not great
in fact petrosian i think more or less
has a winning position already
because this you know this g pawn just
doesn't belong here on g6 so
now hopefully it's really apparent
what's going to be weak it's it's going
to be this these dark squares right
these dark squares and also these light
squares like just every every square
over here on the king's side is going to
be a weakness that petrosian is is going
to try to target
um
so let's see how petrogen continued so
now the chat is probably feeling a lot
better about their h4 idea
but i still think it might be a little
bit premature because something like h5
is going to give black a lot of time and
sort of shut you down not that white is
is ever really
in danger here or anything so instead
petrossian just castles now
we get bishop out to d7
um rook f to e1
queen to c7
and then brian's idea is is actually
going to come through
meaning we want to target these squares
somehow so i sort of spoiled this
already
but black especially after queen c7
looking to get something going on the
queen's side and this is sort of pretty
typical when you have big weaknesses
around your king around your king side
you want to open things up somewhere
way on the other side of the board try
and distract your opponent from the
glaring weaknesses uh on the other side
and use that as as counter play
so i i spoiled it a little bit but the
move that's that's going to stop b5 b4
and lock the action down on on the queen
side is of course this move a4
and that's what protrusion plays in the
game so
i said b6 b5 not super relevant
weaknesses but they're relevant because
we can sort of slow down black's plan
we're not really aiming to you know
occupy these necessarily but we can
definitely slow black down
black plays knight a6 in the game we get
queen to e2
and now king to f8 is uh necking's
choice probably mispronouncing his name
horribly i should look these things up
uh knight f3 by
uh
by protrosion
and now again i want to ask you to try
and find
petrosian's idea here it's going to be
it's going to be a lot harder than than
any ideas i came up with in my games but
let's see if you can come up with a more
long-term plan to go after some of these
dark squares
oh there was a question in the chat why
didn't castle protect the g pawn um
it did but you might get checkmated i
think
that's that's the danger is checkmate
there
i'll have to look at the exact position
actually let me
figure out where we were
just in general i felt i would be having
a blind castle
definitely yeah definitely you're happy
if black castle's there
yeah i can't give you the the exact
refutation off the cuff here but
castle's not a good idea
okay everybody still wants to play h4
it's definitely worth thinking about
subakura says h4 followed by h5 well
that is optimistic
don't know if black is letting you play
h5
try and think about where you want to
put your pieces yeah what do you think
brian
um i have a slow guess uh h3 knight h2
knight g4 to
to go up to f6 and then if they play h5
then we just come back and
try to go to g5 instead
yeah so uh you're along the right track
there like this is more common i think
in um
you know that that other opening that's
uh is somewhat popular i think you know
it's called e4e5 this idea
shows up in those openings a lot but um
here we actually have a faster way to
force this pawn to h5 and i think it's
what the chat was saying uh h4
eventually
is
you know
is probably going to be enticement
enough to to get our opponent to play
something like h5 or some other
weakening move
but
patrician actually doesn't do it
immediately but h4 of course very very
important idea here and we we are going
to see it eventually in this game
oh my god and we we have enrique meking
trivia in in the chat now this is fun
i'll guess
fortunately now he's not joining us
tonight
do we want to move
uh why do you want to do that
like our eventual
goal
is to contest g5 after they play h5 and
i want to move it back to
not lose them
ah okay that makes sense so this bishop
e3 idea is actually what protrosian
plays in the game and i'm a big fan
um but let's try to understand what's
going on here so
uh this might look like a really really
weird move our bishop's sort of you know
tucked in quite nicely in our pawn
structure there
but bishop e3 i think is an important
idea here and i wanted to highlight uh
how important this is to
protrosion's attacking sort of scheme
here so
you might be familiar
in positions where we have a fee
encountered bishop
with the king on g8 the bishop on g7
just like normal position you might be
familiar with the idea that white often
tries to trade off that bishop in order
to attack the king and most players
would be able to tell you uh yes of
course we want to trade off that bishop
because g6 has weakened black's dark
squares
and that is true it's all true but it
turns out it's true in other positions
as well
so this bishop is doing a lot of the leg
work here to keep these dark squares
under control so by removing our bishop
from d4
we're aiming to eventually put this
bishop on g5
and say to black you know you're not
going to be able to keep that bishop
forever
if i can trade that off i'll be able to
access these dark squares a lot more
easily and attack your king a lot more
easily so i think that's the critical
point here behind bishop e3
and why protrosion chooses this move but
once again the chat isn't far off h4 of
course is going to be an important idea
um so bishop e3 we get knights c5 and
then protrosia actually plays this move
knight to d4 so
good square for the knight um we are
we're sort of pretending we might go to
b5
um
technically we can't they can't type
yeah um we're preventing b5 for black
and as brian just pointed out this is
still no good um still no good for for
black
um so knight to d4 and of course what's
the other idea behind moving the knight
uh it's so that the knight's not on f3
so that we can push
with f4
once again
this f4 idea certainly going to be
relevant here as as well
so knight to d4 our opponent plays rook
to a6 i believe petrossian just keeps it
simple place bishop back to c1
uh i don't think we had to do this
immediately we you know could have
relied on this tactic but might as well
just keep it solid
uh and of course the super strong rook
a6 rook to a8 maneuver
unfortunately for black it's it's tough
to do anything here uh this [ __ ] a4
taking advantage of this uh slightly
less important weakness on the queen
side turns out to be really relevant
it's just really it's really hard to uh
to play b5 here or get anything going on
the queen side
uh now petrossian goes with g3
and finally the chat can scream it now
what what's what's the move here
h4 of course you know look at those nice
bishops angling at the uh the king our
queen even on the third diagonal it's
time to push push the h pawn and black
of course is not going to let us get to
h5 because as ugly as these dark squares
look um if you
pass
these light squares are going to look
even uglier and this is also going to be
a hook of course and so how could
white potentially make use of this pawn
on g5
what could we do
yeah at some point f4 is going to come
and we have very easy access to the
black king we're going to open some
files going to be able to attack now
maybe not right away
we're not playing f4 but eventually this
pawn being a hook is is going to be
really annoying so h5 instead
uh
now uh petrossian continues taking his
time goes with queen f3 first
bishop to d2
and now the the key move that i was sort
of talking about earlier how is
protrosion going to continue
to pressure the dark squares
how does he keep up the pressure
yes bishop g5 uh it's it's the perfect
time now once again this bishop doing
all the defensive work over here and
trojan simply takes it off the board
um we get queen to d8
and petrosian now uh just defends the
bishop uh and why do you think
petrossian opts to defend the bishop
rather than just trade with bishop e7
what do you think the the difference is
he's got something sneaky in mind
yeah that's exactly right that's exactly
right
um so two more moves were played but now
we get to see his point bishop g5 he
wants to take this back with the pawn
uh and yeah patricia's just being really
really mean about it uh he's saying your
dark squares are so weak and now he's
going to use both of these pawns to to
really permanently
keep those squares weak and we'll see
that he's going to take this idea
even one step further
so rook to a8 was played and then
petrossian actually comes all the way in
with queen to f6 so mecking is is still
sort of just just passing on the other
side and so you might expect protrosis
to play you know something like rook f3
try and checkmate black but he's
actually happy to just come in with
queen f6 and then the next move may
shock you
it may even terrify you
um queen takes f6 and then believe it or
not not g takes f6 but e takes f6
so what's going on here
what what what is petrosian thinking
just trading the queens against the
opponent's weak king
and uh taking back giving ourselves
double doubled pawns
uh what what is what is the point of it
all what's going on here
first of all
alternatively i immediately saw that
he's got f3 heading
all right so some good points there um i
don't know
how important this pin is is gonna be um
by the time we get our guys over to h1
um black is probably going to be ready
to play play king g8 um
but petrossian actually does start with
king g2 maybe angling to force king g8
and keep this rook sort of entombed
but here we're gonna see that it goes
goes for something else so
um your idea was to go knight f3 to e5
immediately um
that that might be okay but first
petrossian does something to to lock it
down even further which is just put this
pawn onto f4
and
now that things start to become a little
bit more clarified we can kind of see
that petrossian's advantage is is not
slipping at all in fact it's it's just
sort of getting even even stronger
rather than have uh you know this
pressure on the king's side now we've
given ourselves full control over all of
the dark squares in the center of the
board all of the dark squares on black's
king's side
and
using these dark squares our knight is
really going to be able to attack all of
the light squares in
in black's camp as well so f4 another
really cool move
and now
protruding takes his time with it he
does bring this rook to h1 drop this
king back to g8
and now finally knight f3 and knight e5
as we said
uh we get bishop e8 uh bishop d3 just
improving this piece
rook to c8 king to f3 bishop c6 rook to
h2
bishop back to
uh e8 no real discoveries there i think
white would be happy to take and take an
extra pawn
came to e3 rook to c7 king to d4 knight
to b7 and okay
now no more free moves so
what did petrosian do over the last five
ten moves i sort of skipped past them
all he was doing is
understanding that he has a total lock
on this position uh these two pieces
aren't going anywhere we control every
square in the black camp here so no way
to get these pieces out and protrusion
realized black can't do anything useful
so what he did is he brought his king to
the center
um to improve that piece brought his
knight to the ideal square brought us
bishop to the ideal square
and now it's it's time to go so
uh finally let's try and crack things
open now that we have full control and
have improved our pieces to the maximum
yeah b4 is great it also plays against
um this knight c5 idea that black was
aiming for so b4 to start
black just plays knight back to d8
now again we see some funny business
with protrosian moving the rooks
black continues passing
um and then he actually comes through
with with b5 and the point now is that
uh just even this bishop has has now
been
essentially immobilized uh by the way if
it gets too too far away um keep in mind
that these two pawns might become uh
queens with with some sacrificial ideas
a knight c5 played in the game bishop c2
uh knight to d7 rook a3 knight c5
and then of course what is the follow-up
idea to to break things open
how do we actually crack it open now
that we have
uh gained even more space on the queen
side
in the chat says this is the worst black
bishop to ever live i would argue that
the rook is the worst rook to ever live
i would rather be this bishop than this
rook
stuff
alright there's really only one break
left here well i guess two but
one that white was really aiming for
yeah just c4 just finally uh opening
things up over here
black plays knight back to d7
uh protrusion just brings the rook to c3
uh not afraid of trades at all because
again
this rook takes longer to get in the
game than white's rook does for sure
take on e5 take on e5 and continuing to
move the king in
um we're not really worried about taking
this pawn back either just continuing to
improve here rook to c8 and then because
petrosian is so so mean he decides to
win with his king plays king d6 i think
everything is winning here bring the
rook in but he just he brings the king
in as well
um rook c to c1 h4 and then macking had
had enough after h4 and and resigned the
game
uh of course king to e7 uh essentially
is winning a bishop as well as you know
take and then king e7
or rook c4 and then king e7 or rook c4
and then rook c8
everything everything is winning here
um
and
you might not expect um it to be as dire
as it is uh from this position
uh but actually here it's it's already
like plus three and that that's how bad
it is with all these these dark squared
weaknesses but i really really love this
game from trojan because it shows you
how he turns you know just a little bit
of softness in in the black camp you
know a little bit of weakness over here
a little bit of weakness over here but
then all of a sudden after queen g4 g6
position just becomes uh unsalvageable
you know the weaknesses keep compounding
he maneuvers this bishop back to e3
um with this idea that after h4 which
was always going to come it can come out
to g5
and increase these dark square the star
squared control even more and then
finally this queen f6 idea with f4 to
follow and then all of a sudden
just every dark square on the black king
side and in the center uh now belongs to
to white and with that he had all the
time in the world to bring his king in
all the time in the world to play b4 b5
play c4 really anything he wanted to do
at that point was just going to be
totally winning improves his position to
the maximum
and then
uh the hammer comes down
um okay so this game was you know a
little bit higher level than the first
game i showed tonight but uh hopefully
the the ideas are still sort of making
sense here petrosian just needling at
these weaknesses until they become worse
and worse and worse and then eventually
you know the position just sort of wins
itself you can do anything and and win
the game
uh so so questions on this game before
we sort of wrap up here
no questions at all
oh yeah okay castles instead of g6 this
is a good one i forgot about this so
let's castle
and i'll try to do it by myself before
we uh
turn on any helpers here
um i imagine there are a lot of things a
lot of things that win i'm wondering if
just the simple bishop e3 is already
just sort of smashing um i will play the
more respectable move first though which
is something like h4
now you sort of desperately want to play
f6 uh but i think that runs into stuff
like like queen g6 here
uh
so
i don't know it's it's hard to play a
move with black really let's say you
develop my idea is just to go rook h3
rook g3 and i i don't know if you're
you're getting off the ground here
like rook g8
you know knight f3
knight g5 next
um
queen f8 maybe i still come here like it
it starts to look pretty ugly so so
that's that's my attempts i i don't know
how accurate that was let's go ahead and
ask ask the engine overlords that the
engine over do you like uh h4 and wow
okay i'm playing perfectly so far
i'm continuing to play all the best
moves okay rook g3 or g8 is fine
knight f3 is the best queen f8 fates the
best okay who was i kidding i know
everything about chess so
not quite a total refutation here but
but black is definitely in for for a
very very tough game you know white can
castle this way the counter play is is
not coming so quickly and it's it's just
going to be really really tough i was
surprised at how close the engine line i
was there but
that that's it we just activate our
pieces attack the black king and it's
it's going to be really tough queen h5
is coming that's why the computer's
saying g6 is a must like if you play b5
i think queen h5
no never mind my my good luck streak
ends queen f4 though is going to be the
the tough move here
if bishop b8 oh knight each knight h7
is rough and and yeah not a fun position
not a fun position especially if you're
playing g6 when again
you know you might as well play play the
way black played in the game if you're
playing g6 here anyways
um so there you go
was that satisfying enough everybody
did that look did that look painful
enough for black
i hope so
all right any other questions
all right
well in that case i think that is just
about my time uh we do have the
wonderful grand master alex shabalov i
think
this is his last youtube lecture so be
sure you guys stick around for it it's
been a pleasure having the big uh
two-time us champion three-time does ben
know off the top of his head nobody
knows multi-time u.s champion alex
shabalov it's been great having him here
as jim and rez and uh i've been enjoying
his lectures so make sure you guys stick
around for it all right with that as
always my name is caleb denby i want to
thank you all very much for coming out
and watching
this has been the roger 2000 and i will
see you next time
[Music]
you